la ciudad de sillar no puede olvidar
estas casas en las colinas de la ciudad
son testigos de la violencia perpetrada
por el grupo terrorista estado islámico
en la región
400.000 personas vivían en sillar antes
de 2014 hoy 9 años después del genocidio
perpetrado contra La minoría jasidi son
los 150.000 de ellas han regresado
volví en 2017 primero fuimos a sinune
donde nos quedamos casi un año la casa
Era alquilada y después de un tiempo no
podíamos pagarla Así que volvimos aquí
no muy lejos de las ruinas de su antigua
casa esta familia de nueve ahora vive en
dos pequeñas habitaciones reconstruidas
con la ayuda de varias ong
salimos del campamento Porque allá
también era difícil todos los días había
una carpa que se incendiaba antes
solíamos tener ganado aquí pero incluso
eso ha cambiado y sin lluvias es
imposible sin salario ni ingresos
difícil vivir aquí no hay electricidad
Así que nos vemos obligados a comprar
diesel Que es caro
la firma de los acuerdos de sing yar en
2020 entre Bagdad y las autoridades
kurdas prometía la reconstrucción de la
provincia pero el acceso a los servicios
públicos sigue siendo limitado
iniciativas locales e internacionales
intentan responder a las necesidades de
la población a la entrada de la ciudad
Se está construyendo un hospital
financiado por el gobierno francés
todos los centros médicos de cinear solo
presentan servicios de atención primaria
este centro cuenta con salas de
operaciones camas y todos los equipos e
instrumentos médicos
25 camas de hospital dos salas de
operaciones y una sala de partos las
obras finalizarán a finales de año los
responsables del proyecto esperan que
este sirva para convencer a los
habitantes de volver
antes de este proyecto de hospital y
todavía si alguien Dear se enferma o
necesita cirugía tiene que conducir
entre una hora y media y dos horas para
llegar a telafar o amozul a pesar de
estos esfuerzos El regreso a hillar no
es fácil para los yacidíes el genocidio
perpetrado por el grupo terrorista
estado islámico dejó cicatrices muy
profundas y esta minoría religiosa
oprimida durante mucho tiempo se siente
ignorada por las autoridades iraquíes
que tardan en actuar pueden ver que
quemaron el segundo piso de la casa
ha faltado una mejor opción y su familia
se instalaron aquí en diciembre de 2020
se hace difícil muy rápido
porque cada día que voy a trabajar paso
por delante de una fosa común en la
calle
Eso es muy duro y me recuerda lo
sucedido todos los días
todos nosotros como jóvenes de sillar
debemos asumir nuestras
responsabilidades e intentar salvar la
provincia chile
lo que necesitamos ahora es apoyo apoyo
de un programa que mantenga la paz en la
zona y para que haya una sola autoridad
que controle la zona y no varios actores
diferentes
nadie entra en detalles sobre la actual
situación de seguridad el ejército
iraquí las milicias yacidíes siguen
luchando por el control de synjar Esas
últimas lucharon contra el grupo
terrorista estado islámico en 2014 junto
al pkk el partido de los trabajadores de
kurdistán y ahora se niegan a evacuar la
provincia ante los actos de violencia
del año pasado miles de habitantes
volvieron a huir una quincena de
familias se encontraron refugio en estas
caravanas en el campamento de mamrayán
cerca de duoc
volvía sin
el primero de mayo hubo enfrentamientos
y la situación no era buena
Así que volvimos al campamento
estábamos justo en medio de sus
enfrentamientos
nadie sabía lo que estaba pasando
si alguien disparaba a mi casa no sabía
a quién dirigirme para quejarme
A quién acudiría al ejército iraquí o a
los otros al PK
no sabemos quién gobierna la zona no hay
nadie
por eso perdí la esperanza No volveré a
sin llave
su vecina no es tan rotunda Pero espera
garantías de las autoridades iraquíes y
kurdas
soy una de las personas que volvió allá
Durante seis años pero una vez más todo
nuestro trabajo Fue en vano hasta que
las autoridades no reconozcan plenamente
el genocidio no podremos regresar no
volveremos
el reconocimiento del genocidio por
parte de Irak como exigen los días le
daría a cada familia el derecho a
recibir una indemnización pero las
autoridades solo prometen negociaciones
para implementar el acuerdo de 2020 sin
embargo un decreto ministerial
promulgado el pasado diciembre Les
devolvió el derecho a la propiedad que
les había sido arrebatado en 1975
durante una campaña de arabilización un
pequeño rayo de Esperanza esta familia
podría reclamar un terreno que ahora le
pertenece al Estado pero tienen muchas
dudas sobre su regreso